welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm your host grace Helbig very
exciting day today we're talking to Shan
boo DRAM who is a wonderful Hugh Mann I
mean that's that on that she's a
sexologist she's a youtuber she's
someone that is so sex positive and
informed and cool and interesting and
taught me things about my body and
myself that I didn't know and that you
should know so this was a really
wonderful conversation enjoy this
episode of not too deep too deep I am so
excited to tell you about a podcast that
you need to have in your regular
rotation whether you've only binge the
office or you've watched every episode
20 times or you're the you're gonna lose
your goddamn mind and if you are an
office fan you already know that this
exists but if you're not guess what
there's a new podcast called office
ladies that's right Jenna Fischer and
Angela Kinsley who you know play Pam and
Angela on the office our office ladies
and best friends in real life and
they're recapping on their podcast every
single episode of the show and then
they're also sharing behind the scenes
stories that no one has heard before
this is bonkers to me and they're two
incredibly lovely women and that I you
know idolized on the office I auditioned
many times for many roles on the office
neither one that they portrayed but you
know never got there but you know fully
respect it's nothing but wonderful get
into it immediately office ladies is out
now listen and subscribe on your podcast
out again office ladies out now on your
podcast app get it
[Music]
shann thank you for being here that's it
yeah okay is casual it wasn't a lie it's
very conversational I mean I can try and
do a pro intro but it will be terrible
no I'm so excited that you're here I
have many questions but you also I want
you to feel like you're in a safe space
where you answer so many questions
constantly all the time that if you want
to pass on any of these and take a
breather you can okay that's what these
questions are actually because you
tweeted it there was some people who
tweeted and I saw the responses yeah and
I was learning I know what shrimping was
okay well that's what I was gonna ask
you cuz I there's a lot that you talk
about that I don't know and I love being
educated because I feel like things are
constantly updating and there's a lot of
people talk about that I don't know I
think that's the thing with sexuality we
look at it like a two week course in
school and then you're done it is a
lifelong challenge to get to know all
the options to express yourself sexually
and I'm sure because you're an expert in
this world that so many people come up
to you with the assumptions that you
know so many different things and so
much terminology that you probably I
don't know I'm being like tell me yet
Bangkok she was on a podcast recently
they gave me the word chode yeah do you
know what a chode is it's like um um
isn't it like a small wide dick yes yeah
it's a penis that's more wide than long
yeah and it's growing up I remember it
was a term of like not endearment to
people yes it was a put-down that people
would use and because it's just a funny
sounding word regardless of what it
actually is the definition of it sounds
like automata PS sometimes in my brain
no this is very exciting you're coming
off of or you might be still in the
midst of your book tour yeah how is that
been oh it's been fantastic I think what
we do so often because I'm a sexologist
I'm not a sexologist in the way that I
work in a clinic or I work with a lot of
one-to-one yeah I do a counseling
service on Sundays but it's like Skype
only and it's like an ancillary part of
my business majority of my business is
spreading information to the masses and
so that just usually means you five
people in the room and that's it so when
you're actually like meeting human
beings
where this has impacted a part of their
lives that I think is massively
overlooked and they're saying things to
you like girl I had my fourth you know
my first four time orgasm yesterday
because of you are I'm in this great
relationship like those the moments
you're like wow like we are really doing
the work here so it made me very proud
well it must be interesting because I'm
sure you've faced a lot of like
negativity when you explained what your
profession is and like the world that
you've consistently educated yourself on
and probably felt like you had to like
prove yourself in so many ways and that
this profession is important and is
making a difference
much like yourself I'm sure well that's
you're one of the first sort of like
YouTube and just like digital as a means
to like communicate with people can be
looked upon as like less than in terms
of entertainment if that's the quality
that you're trying to get people to
understand you on but I you must like
how do you face that sort of like
backlash or negativity I'm sure you can
pick up on it pretty quickly when you're
talking to someone of like they don't
think what I do is valid yeah I think
I've been in this space for 13 years so
in the beginning my mom's first initial
thought when I told her what I was doing
was don't you realize there's gonna be
boys in rooms just laughing and
masturbating and now looking back what a
vision but yeah I think that in the
initial stages of my career there was so
much fear so much constant pushback I
went to school for journalism as my base
okay my professors told me to change my
focus like with a lot of discouragement
I think as time has gone on it's gotten
a little bit better and I've learned
that you have to be the change you wish
to see in the world and that you are
actually responsible for a lot of how
people feel about what you do so I was
actually going to speak at University of
Delaware two years ago and this is when
I was really like in my [ __ ] like I
talked about sex and relationships and
not making any more apologies no matter
where I go cuz sometimes I used to have
over answers you know where you're like
I don't wanna get into it here's my uber
answer like I'm an educator yeah that's
it yeah and I'm like no I'm actually
trying to pave the way for people behind
me and I have to normalize the career so
I'm saying when everyone asks mmm so
this lady picked me up from the airport
she's like the driver for this school
and she's like 90 years old or something
yeah she's probably 60 but you know it's
hard to tell
with children they're either a newborn
or they're 13 I don't know any
in-between for those two things I'm sure
she was a 90 cuz I don't know if 90 year
olds driving but anyhow she's in Delhi
so you're coming to Delaware to speak
like what's your topic and I was like
I'm going to speak about sex and silent
in the car and then she's like so do you
mean like why not to have sex how to use
condoms like aids the risk of AIDS and
then I was like nah it's really more
about how to have a bomb-ass sex life
and one that you're really proud of and
have great orgasms and also be safe but
it's not a focal point of my talk dead
silent in the car and I could feel the
judgment and I wanted to add in the oh
but we'll also be talking about Justin I
wanted to I'm like sit in it sit in your
space and in two minutes later she said
you know what my first husband couldn't
find my [ __ ] if it was on his nose and
the rest of the car ride she just went
in so it was great that was my lesson
amazing but what a great boundary to
like play chicken with fur second like
that's so great and I think I mean it
must be so rewarding the feedback that
you get because you're normalizing
things that people have associated with
shame and like embarrassment so often
has this book tour because the book is
half these like real stories of women
that have followed your guidance and
have discovered you know many different
mile markers for themselves it sounds
like and like half self-help have you
found that the response from people
because it's like actual testimonials
and self-help have been like that much
more impactful yeah I mean I refer to
myself as like a Mary Poppins of some
sort like I want to put your medicine
and sugar yeah that was actually when I
was 19 years old I started in this space
and my acknowledgement was there's great
information in the books educational
books but porn is real interesting
interesting carrier characters really
salacious yeah story lines good-looking
people and so that's more appetizing to
consume so I was like there needs to be
somebody who bridges the gap and makes
sex education sexy makes learning about
love fun and interesting is just as
compelling as Gossip Girl
which you know contributed Gossip Girl
and the book the coldest winter ever
wishing might no Melissa do you yeah the
coldest winter ever is like books that
like really
made a big difference on me and they
were lies like it was peddling and the
coldest winter ever she had sex for the
first time and the penis just ever so
slightly entered her and she orgasm I
God I was like that sex right notes
expectations now set and when I
obviously didn't have that experience I
turned to books and I was like there's
great information but it's boring and so
even with the game of desire it's my way
of saying hey there's a way to be good
at connecting with people mm-hmm I don't
think I'm actually naturally a people
person I'm somebody who used to make
life a lot harder for myself based on my
personality but I learned about
seduction I learned about flirting I
learned how to connect and not only did
my romantic relationships improve and
I'm married now in tting to the nicest
person in the world hmm
that's a great quality my life overall
has just improved so for me I'm like I
want people to learn what I've learned
the past 13 years from reading all these
great psychological books but how do I
make it more compelling yeah and how did
you were there any influences or major
ones that you discovered that made it
more palatable made it more digestible
made it more like oh it can be fun okay
I think Esther Perel is kind of like the
new-age version of person who's making
the information I don't know how she's
even doing it because I have to meet
with her really oh my gosh you go go and
you will do I Esther Perel
okay yes she actually is sort of like
the new version of dr. roots she's an
older lady okay
and she talks about relationship she's
extremely smart and wise and she's able
to really capture a younger audience and
make people really think about love and
relationships I think Matthew Hussey is
also incredible I love Matthew hussies
work there's a lot of people I think in
the space who are emerging in this way I
just occupy a different space as a woman
of color but yeah I think that there's
tons of great people who are finding
ways to get the average person thinking
hmm beyond my horoscope how can I get
better at understanding myself and
applying that knowledge for better
relationships yeah okay so because
you're sexologist and and but you do a
lot of like psychological work with
people because you had this show make up
or break up yeah is it still on no no
that's a ship that sailed I miss it
every day but the concept is great
basically counselling having
conversations with people that are on
the verge of technically breaking up
mm-hmm
how what were some of the craziest
scenarios that you had to are the most
difficult or challenging scenarios in
that situation because it's like a live
conversation that you're having yes what
I loved about that show the most was
that it empowered the audience to also
weigh in I think that I want to get to
like my ultimate career goal is to get
to a space where I empower people to
feel like their own relationship expert
mmm cuz to your point is kind of this
weird area whenever people hear what I
do they like that's so nice I'm like I
didn't say I was studying hardwood
floors three people in the world should
know yeah everybody should be studying
this area and so I think gone are the
days of the experts who sit atop the
mountain and doled out information bit
by bit column by column yeah you have
this podcast you are an expert to me you
are in communion with your people people
trust you you read your research you
listen like you show up you are an
expert in this area and I want everyone
to feel like no I have a say I have
experience as relative I read I know my
[ __ ] so I can apply it to help others
and make up or break up was actually
based on that empowering every single
person to feel like no like you can
listen and weigh in and it's called
wisdom of the crowd uh-huh where if we
were to guess this is the weirdest prop
right here oh sorry yeah we have a tiny
toddler looking baby doll that sits on
the desk it's like dirty a little bit it
was very dirty and it's wearing a bee
suit but if this was a jar of jellybeans
and we were to try to guess how many
though if we pooled like 200 people the
average number would be probably the
closest number so that's like to say
that you know we be together and AI
actually operates on wisdom of the crowd
as well anyhow but that show the most
interesting one I remember is this dude
was addicted to Mountain Dew and with
the beverage beverage okay yes I didn't
know that was like a sexual innuendo no
you shrimping Mountain Dew no yeah he
was addicted to Mountain Dew and when
they first got together he was it
sounded casual but then it was like no
like this guy was hiding Mountain Dews
places and you know yeah so that was
fascinating because we just think about
addiction in a very linear way yeah that
was interesting did they stay at
gather is that a spoil I think they've
got a breakup vote okay okay I mean yeah
that's a tough one like they can't walk
into a 7-eleven together
so how did okay speaking before about
your husband and I'm sure you get asked
all the time the dating world being
someone that is basically giving advice
about dating and sex how did you guys
meet each other oh we met through a
mutual friend okay so the number one way
to meet people is still meeting through
a mutual friend is that true number two
is online dating Wow
that might actually change cuz match.com
recently put out a new survey so maybe
that's superseded that by now but then
you have places what does it hinge that
says like you have these people in
common you have basically like me
meeting through your friends but on it
have you tried hinge before I have not I
only tried can't do that stuff I only do
I did one date I did the riah situation
yeah I met a person that I did date for
a long time and then broke up with on
Raya but we had known of each other in
real life previous to both using that
app and then it just became a second job
a big hey it was very exciting and like
gamified in a way at first and then it
just became overwhelming and as someone
that doesn't like like it feels like I
have pretty perceptive tendencies and
like will make an immediate kind of
decision of like whether I'm into
someone or not I just didn't want to
keep leaving my house and wasting my
time which is hard yeah so you guys met
through a mutual friend yes so you
didn't know about each other at all no
he was literally a person I saw at a
party and I remember having the thought
like he'd be a great revenge [ __ ] but it
took a year after that for us to
actually meet up and really true to that
we were so I was in a long distance I'm
from Canada originally yeah so I'd moved
to California and it was my first year
there and I saw this guy at the party he
was just so cute yeah and I'm like I
wanted to dance with me I want him to
and he Deneb heezen even remember seeing
me that night right before meeting me
and it was like a moment in time for me
so it's kind of half because I wasn't
followed him on Instagram afterwards cuz
we met through that mutual friend and I
scrolled to that guy's profile so I
found a picture and I was like got him
yeah and then it took a year after this
after that for us to actually meet up
Wow so it's almost like you manifested
it in a way forced stock to you bested
that's the nice what the universe do
what it did and liked his photos
periodically him once every three months
and since a long birthday message you
know just the universe doing its thing
well yeah it wasn't I didn't put more
time or energy into it than he was of
course yeah did was it intimidating for
him to be getting involved with someone
that this is there 24/7 profession I
would love to follow this question back
to you because I get asked all the time
yeah I'm like I would never be attracted
to somebody who was intimidated by my
line of work right he would show up
right away in our conversations I often
say this that people are like I bet
dudes are like oh yes I did too like I
might be opposite I feel like dudes try
to compete with me as almost as if they
think by me saying I study sex that what
I'm really saying is child could have
sex with your partner better than you
you know much better in lover than you
so I find that men don't ask me
questions they try to qualify their
expertise whereas in women are very
comfortable asking questions I think
that will change with time but
ultimately yeah he was not intimidated
at all he was he loved it and he comes
from a very Christian family Oh interest
yes definitely the devil that like
ruined him for a while it was like there
was rumors going around about us because
we had an open relationship as well too
way so the church had a field day with
that I think you the quality you want
and someone when you are a very
career-driven person in a lot of ways is
you want someone that's impressed and
supporting of your career rather than
intimidated yes yes don't ignore it
either I think yeah that's the thing I
don't act like it's not interesting or
not something unique or different you
have to give it the space all right have
you ever dated somebody that you felt
was intimidated or tried to compete
yeah I've dated people that for sure
have seemingly been supportive but have
kind of behind the scenes been
competitive or
like agitated about like their kind of
comparison of like where we're at in our
careers both at the same time rather
than being just like purely supportive
mm-hmm and so it's yeah I was very
difficult and you don't wanna when you
really are into that person you don't
want to acknowledge that that's how
they're feeling and that they're making
you feel bad and they don't really know
it so you just keep going like it
they'll be happy again you can also not
prove that yes you cannot call someone
out for that behavior because they let
me be like that's not true
that's your assuming my feeling since I
am but I think I'm pretty right but you
have this how has your career or your
relationship with your career changed
since being married it has or at all
yeah I often referred to marriage is the
thing because I'm not religious and I
don't come from my family that it was
pressured for me to get married I didn't
want to have I've been married for you
know almost a year now and we haven't
had kids or start embarked on still of
an IUD and so I wasn't getting married
to have kids like the only real reason
we were getting marry still we live
together was to prepare people to
understand our connection Oh interest so
it was mostly about like just like you
go I think to school so other people
understand what your passion is you can
create a title that like oh I get what
you are yeah I think that we viewed
marriage the same way like we had an
incredible connection he's my partner we
had a production company together like I
love my life with him and it was getting
other people to quickly understand what
that meant
right so marriage I don't I don't think
that marriage made our I get that
question a lot like yeah how has
marriage changed things for you and I
feel dislike I'm disappointing someone
when I'm like it's the same [ __ ] yeah we
basically did it so like everyone
looking from the outside in knew that we
were legit in love with each other
wonderful romantic thing yes that's my
person that's my best friend in like I
never get sick of a man yeah I there I'm
glad that marriage didn't change things
because I said yes to what we're doing
I'm like I could do this forever
that's when I said yes if he would have
leveled up and all of a sudden it
started I don't know shooting rainbows
at his ass some extra thing that
happened after marriage I'd be cool but
it wasn't required yeah no that's a very
grounded way to look at that because yet
you don't
necessarily want things to change after
you get married for better or worse
because how can you trust that that's
the reality now yeah and when I meet
people sometimes who were like marriage
changed everything you're like that's
fascinating tell me more like we're just
closer we know each other more we have
each other's back and then you're like
that's great you keep asking and I'm
like yeah because we just moved in
together I'm like okay that's why you're
closer it looks like you have to have a
choice are you guys but still good job
are the vibrator necklace is still
available yes did I not give you one no
my gosh I'm a hater no no you're not
you're an incredible creative genius
because that when I read that these
existed I was like huh what how I'm
disappointed the UI should have been
sent a package with like the book
because the book came with like a
starter kit like a designer starter kit
I 100% will get you one oh no worries no
but this is like a very ingenious
product to me how did this come about
for you I want to say full-frontal I
have the exact same route I had the
exact same reaction as you when I found
out about it yeah that to be said it
already existed okay it was just oh my
god she's so unprofessional
oh no it's great she's booked and busy
oh yeah no I get calls it literally say
fraud risk
oh my say scam likely but yeah the
vibrator necklace is by a company named
crave the designers woman named T she's
a design furniture okay and she wanted
to bring that sort of clean chic
ingenuity to sex toys and so it I saw it
at an expo and I met her and I was like
I love this product like this to me
represents what I think about when I
think about my sexuality it's chic it's
discreet yeah it's fun it's mysterious
and in public you know if I want to
reveal that to you right because people
are often looking it and they'll be like
oh is that like a railroad nail file
what is that it looks like a very
artistic piece of jewelry yes you would
never know had you not explained it or
had it not just set it on the website
when I
I think poised often there was this in
school we researched how our attitudes
towards sex were
didn't porn and so in America we have
this very bizarre relationship with our
sexuality we're in one hand it's
exaggerated in media but it's super
repressed in our education system and of
course if you grew up in the Bible Belt
area I extremely repressed by your
family community etc and so this weird
dichotomy puts us in a place where we're
not really comfortable as ourselves as
sexual beings yeah and so our porn looks
larger than life the world's greatest
biggest dick the world from the most
massive boobs like it's you don't see
yourself when you're watching porn right
we're in countries like Sweden or
Thailand where sexuality is more of a
normal part of life and the celebrated
part of life the porn looks like
everyday people Oh interesting
I think our sex toys the point I was
making when you go to our sex taste toy
store it's just like really embarrassing
they're good silly looking goofy and so
you're like why would I that this looks
embarrassing and like who chose these
colors like why does it look to be this
like a most ridiculous only natural
having sex under a black light and if
you are that's kind of cool I mean good
for you I'm sure there are people that
that's their thing but like I don't need
to look like an alien is [ __ ] me all
the time no that's why I respect it so
much because it is beautiful it's like
it's functional and pretty like at the
same time so it's like dual purpose I
think it's really cool and I hope that
they continue to go in that realm where
it's like fashion and function the same
day they have one that's like a USB I
think it has like you know a couple gigs
of storage on it that's also a vibrator
so while you're in your computer to do
the USB business it's also charging
that's incredible what okay the future
is now this is uh amazing okay we're
gonna take a quick break when we get
back I have some more questions for you
especially apology languages which I've
never heard about before until I watched
your video yours I know I haven't even
had a second to look it would I go over
the break that would take a long time
though I will do it for sure but I want
to hear a little bit more about what
they are because I had I'm big into love
languages so apology language just makes
sense that it exists but I'm so curious
okay we'll be right back with more not
too deep
[Music]
today we have support from light box if
you like diamonds if you like bling if
you like walking into the room and
having the reflection of your aura shine
on everyone then this might be the thing
for you light box makes gorgeous
lab-grown diamonds which are essentially
chemically the same as natural ones
except they're made in a lab to make
them they put a tiny piece of lab-grown
diamond into a plasma reactor and heat
it up to temperatures almost as hot as
the Sun science I don't fully understand
it but it's science and then in about
two weeks the seed turns into a full
carat stone every stone is made the same
every time so they're also priced the
same every time at $800 per carat
they've even cracked the science of
color creating gorgeous gems in pink and
blue so treat yourself to a little
sparkle you earned it
go to lightbox jewelry comm slash Grace
and use code grace for $25 off again
that's lightbox jewelry dot-com slash
Grace and use code grace for $25 off
okay we're back in looking at five long
love languages and apology languages
right now oh I don't want to get started
right now okay but you just explained
what what's your love language my love
language I feel like and tell me if this
is wrong too because I feel like it
shifts occasionally like you don't have
just like one love language for the rest
of your life I feel like I've noticed
for myself that I've taken the quiz in
different relationships and it often
reflects what I'm not getting in that
specific relationship and so it's gone
in different routes but for primarily
its words of encouragement and acts of
service hmm yeah like if someone takes
my garbage out I'm just like they've
truly care about me like they see me
that I need like that done and my dad
who was like that ya know it's very
reflective in that too that like my dad
takes care of all the tasks that might
like flighty creative brain doesn't know
I just got my oil change for the first
time ever like two months ago
an adult so they did a lot of things
that I've never had to like figure out
and how to deal with but yeah but words
of encouragement to is a big one which
is fascinating because I think as
somebody who gets so much praise on the
internet people would assume that you're
all like full at the end well yeah I
guess so but and that's always I've
always had a very difficult time like
accepting that sort of praise and they
trying because the idea of like humility
is always such a quality value of the
Internet well yeah I just value that I
think the people that are really good at
what they do don't like fixate on that
instead they just like it and concern
themselves with like maintaining the
quality of what they're doing and so
it's always hard to be like oh thank you
thank you but like when there's the
person that I value them so much like
treat people how you want to be treated
like that person that is my number one
for them to tell me something
that has like significant emotional
value it's like very important yes yeah
yes and important to note I think I
learned that it's important to know that
about people you work with I'm just
working on to make up or break up in the
showrunner there she's such a badass to
do like black is black white is white go
do this go do that person and you would
assume that her love language would be
access service because she just should
get it done kind of person but she was
words of affirmation that she needed to
hear from people because she rarely did
yeah like you're doing a great job like
thank you for your leadership you're
awesome you're on fire and so and it's
so interesting it's interesting to like
figure that out not just about people
you love people you care about to answer
your question about can they switch
absolutely yeah I don't mind a switcher
my pet peeve are people who are like I'm
all five everyone likes gifts like
nobody out here is like well I don't
want a hug like everyone likes um in
moderation right the purpose of love
languages and apology languages is
clarity because we here in relationships
that communication is key but we don't
get instruction on exactly do you say
and so for example if I'm sure if you I
asked you how do I get here and you're
like you could take the 110 the 115 or
the 95 do kind of depends what you feel
like if you want to go to Tripoli I'm
lost yeah I don't know actually have to
go somewhere else to look it up and I
may end up getting it wrong or getting
here late so it's you're trying to give
somebody here's a to be yeah you know if
you see me in a low point and you want
to pick my mood up here
your best bet to doing it and so if I
ask you what do you want to eat for
dinner and you're like I don't really
know that's a lot less helpful than
Chinese yeah so it's creating clarity so
that number one your partner understands
you and two they feel competent in doing
for you without having to be asked
because they know where to go they know
how to drive to that route successfully
yeah and once they know that route back
and forth start adding in some extra
stops that's when you can start creating
it but you need that initial clearness
and I think like apology languages for
example knowing my partner's apology
language has blown my mind that's why
learning that this exists I'm like so
eager to now go back and find out mine
find out my boyfriend's find out my
closest friends because I feel like
there's so much clarity and hindsight
looking back and going oh that's why
that resolution didn't actually feel so
strong because that person was accepting
an apology but not in the way that they
wanted it or it took hours longer than
it probably should have yeah yeah I
think it's so fascinating because that's
a I remember when I first learned about
love languages I was at the end of a
very tumultuous relationship that was
like trying to hang on and just like
wasn't working like square pegs in round
holes it was just like infuriating and
then cyclical infuriating and in a way
to like add closure to the relationship
we both took the love languages quiz and
like eyes wide open was like oh my god
this is when your love language this
whole time I have not been doing a
single thing that it would have helped
you feel loved and vice versa and it was
like oh yeah okay maybe we aren't
compatible and this is actually really
helpful to go it wasn't any of us
maliciously trying to hurt each other
it's just a misunderstanding of like
needs and expectations and so it was
actually very helpful especially just
getting out of a relationship just
putting that out there for anyway you
can always learn to adopt a love
language I totally we had just gone so
far past the finish line already that it
was like okay this is nice I hope you
like look for someone now that you know
this yeah like this is clarity for you
and I'm gonna be very happy for you
moving forward cuz I think you have some
more understanding of yourself now okay
what do you do to relax
oh you know what I'm gonna see the
cliche thing and it's definitely orgasm
it's a really big part of my wellness
yeah in my life I love running I love
listening to audiobooks I just love
spending time with my my partner I think
that actually we spend an inordinate
amount of time together it's gonna ask
you get to spend time together
Oh a lot and so the other day I was like
do you think it's weird that we spend
those time together he's like yes and I
was like I love it so yeah I think also
too yeah
learning is relaxing for me I love if I
feel stressed out actually having a
to-do list also it really helps oh yeah
just knocking things off just to feel
like I'm in control so I also had this
activity I do once every four months
where I do a list of things I love about
myself
things that I'm not so happy or that
bother me daily and things I'm neutral
about and then I try to look at that
list of things that bother me and I try
to find a plan of action to move that up
or down because there's some things that
like bothered a guy like you know girl
that's just gonna be who you are
yeah late today I'm gonna be late
tomorrow like that's just until I also
enjoy it though cuz when someone's late
for me I'm like not stressed out about
it oh no that's how I found late to
everything so that's why I'm like yeah
you can go to the bathroom you can hang
around we can just talk for like 20
months before we start it's okay I
understand that that that thing that
quality right I also acknowledge it's
not a great trait like my partner is on
time
and it is I see how people respond to
him and how people rely on him to do
stuff and I think that's nice maybe one
day how do you do you work from home
primarily yeah I don't think I mean
people ask that question my life is
never the same yeah I think week to week
I'm going on the doctor's tomorrow yeah
so then on the weekend I'm doing this
like women's empowerment video that's
like us and our underwear and we're
doing it like we're shooting it in
public and so okay I think my weeks are
always different my favorite weeks yeah
are just from home are just some home
yeah I think I'm an ambivert
and that means like I'm good at
extraversion and I understand
extraversion and why it's necessary but
truly I need a lot of a line alone time
to recharge too
extraversion ya ambivert I've never
heard that phrase before that's great
yeah cuz I get that too I really
consider myself an introvert but people
like but you're interested you're out
talking to people all the time like yeah
it makes me very tired like I could be
at home for a very long period of time
and people be like are you okay and I
think I'm living my best life like I'm
having a great time are you okay
but ambivert makes a lot of sense to me
how do you generate the ideas for your
videos does that come from like
crowdsourcing of like conversations with
the audience does it come from things
that you stumble upon that you generally
feel is necessary to talk about or a
combination I think I do what works I do
what people are asking for and I do
what's interesting to me at the time
yeah like I did a video on apology
languages because like you and I found
that out I was like and so you look for
a unique and interesting way again kind
of being the Mary Poppins that medicine
and sugar like how do I make this
fascinating to the audience it can't
just be straightforward in clinical and
so I try to find as much life experience
to I can apply to things because people
are attracted to stories human interest
deeply matters to people I often say
there's a lot of like not-so-great
things about me on the internet but
everything you read by the internet
that's not good I told y'all I made a
video about it I told you I'm not hiding
anything yes it must be interesting that
you get met with scrutiny because people
don't understand or they look down or
they get defensive or offensive by
something that you say like how do you
maintain is it just a matter of like I
need to get a head of air I have to be
my most authentic transparent self I
feel like there's a balance that has to
be struck because I acknowledge that I
am trying to make a not so popular topic
very popular and it's a popular topic
but not to learn about yeah it's a
popular topic to gossip about to
complain about to joke about not what I
say to learn about and so I also again
my root is journalism that's my first
thing I went to school for so I stories
yeah and I acknowledge that like I
there's this story on Valley
that is in my book yes so this is a big
thing right now I've seen because people
have kind of taken an excerpt from your
book about vaping which I would love for
you in your words explain what that is
and kind of have twisted it yes I also
acknowledge that's why I put it in the
book yeah because I know this is going
to be something that's interesting
that's going to get shared and the book
has tons of not so fascinating and
salacious and headline worthy
information but if that headline is what
draws you to the book so be it so
because I acknowledge what it is that
I'm doing and again I'm going back to
that first seat I thought sex education
is not sexy yes not fun it's not
interesting it's not newsworthy it's not
shareable so I have to create content
that is that and sometimes that's at the
sacrifice of my perspective into other
people's eyes and I'm not okay with it
no that's amazing to feel that
comfortable with that because that can
be very tough and very like just
emotionally exhausting yeah the can you
explain for people what that is yes
because it's a really cute
phrase but I think some people might
have a visceral reaction to it or have
already I think that's from vaping was
created by Carly Aquino okay
no I only know because you've tweeted
will tag me into the post a piece is
Carly's term oh my god not and on top of
that vaping is not created by any per
person in modern history so right it's
the use of pheromones to draw people in
okay I mean so essentially you would
take a sample of your vaginal fluids
from your Barthel england so you're not
taking it from like the labia majora
minora where you no discharge collects
taking a fresh sample from the opening
and you're applying it as you would
apply perfume so to your pressure point
so that would be like inside your elbow
area on your wrists on your neck at the
back of your neck wherever your body
absorbs and distributes heat because
that creates the smell emits the smell
and so the purpose of doing this is so
that your pheromones or your cocktail
ends might draw other people in and make
them more attracted to you okay yeah it
has a grounding in science and when you
describe it it's a very scientific
approach to this situation but I think
people see it as like a ridiculous
YouTube challenge type of video yeah
which is kind of true cuz it really
hasn't been scientifically proven and
also too because we live in a world with
so many competing sense yeah my hair is
a dome of its own so anything to
supersede that scent it's gonna have to
be really strong sure on top of that too
we live in like even the same thing with
crystal
right like yes a jade crystal does emit
energy but in a world where there's
highways and cars and like subways
there's so many vibrations
yeah the chance is that that small rock
is emitting enough to actually make a
literal impact on you is slim ya mean
placebo though that's a thing yeah so I
think that the babble osebo it is did
you have any results that word let's
wait in one way or the other of whether
this is a valuable thing to do
listen thing I've kind of done it off
and on for 10 years okay I remember it's
not a thing that it's like a daily thing
and sometimes I'll forget I did it
because there's zero reaction from
people it's just nothing I remember this
one time I went out to a club so it's
best to use either in a club or in a
date you have to be in very close
proximity with people and it should be
at a place where like that's sort of the
vibe I wear a suit at a playground so
I'm never going to a club once and
literally like I think I have my hair up
I was like not one of those days where I
was like done up you know every person
was like your soul is beautiful
compliments were so specific indeed but
I was like wow and I told a friend of
mine and she worked in promotions and so
she was like outdoor working with a
bunch of guys like on some alcohol
promotion and she was like it is crazy
they're talking to me she's like I can't
pick up a chair I can't do any work we
got them you're rushing over Wow but
then again like I said I've had times
I've had nothing yeah in the book when
we did it we went to Soho House okay and
the girls in the group were like I kind
of noticed people were leaning in but
it's a loud Club yeah it's also a place
for people I think are more specifically
looking around and be like who is who
next we're just moving around anyways I
mean it's fascinating
have you had stories that people tried
it since reading your book yes this girl
said it got her some tater tots at a
restaurant that's all the scientific
proof I think it's actually one of the
Amazon reviews that she wrote and that
that happened that's incredible yes Wow
three tots tots
what are your targeted ads like on your
phone or what comes up mostly on your
explore page
very fascinating I can imagine the types
of conversations you have near your
phone must generate some bizarre or very
specific ads I wish I would actually am
NOT as cognizant of that you know I only
what I did notice is that recently I
went to BCBG and I bought a lot of stuff
I never searched online though cuz I'm
not an online clothes shopper yeah all
of a sudden the BCBG ads like all on my
phone and I was like that's slightly
uncomfortable and just because you were
in the stove maybe I'm like maybe I did
search it maybe I search into my email I
couldn't recall but um no I haven't
gotten any really great ads tanked now's
the time now that we've talked about it
so we're sleeping mine so I was like
really sick the other week and I was
like waking up with like night sweats
and then literally like two days later I
was on a plane and got like a targeted
ad for a Buffy comforter that's like it
says tired of waking up sweaty
I do feel seen I did buy the blanket
it's wonderful and I love it very much
now but yeah it's a the Vampire Slayer
Buffy the Vampire Slayer but not
associated at all but this spelled the
same way okay yeah Buffy I wish that
they sponsor this podcast so I would've
been a lot easier for me but and it's
great love it but that was like oh very
weird and specific yeah but it worked
which is even more frightening I know
that's the thing is that I want to be
scared of it and like mad at it but then
seems like quite convenient yeah because
then you're like oh this a nice clothes
where is this from yeah yeah it's it's
it's a bummer did you have any fictional
sexual icons growing up fictional sexual
icons I would say coldest winter ever
which is winter Santiago okay terrible
icon to have but sure enough that was
one of them there was a porn that I
watched very frequently don't know the
lady's name back then it was VHS porn
because I'm born in 85 so yeah I mean
yeah like this this the cusp yeah and my
parents there's one VHS porn and this
woman her husband took her into a clinic
to get [ __ ] because she wasn't having
pleasure in their marriage was actually
a very progressive you know
just like Tim this is super progressive
and I feel like this really had an
influence on where your life and she
went to different rooms to get treated
by different people and like it was
girl-on-girl sometimes and sometimes it
was by a vibrator so interesting she was
very influential to me don't know where
you are in life but she's a huge fan of
the podcast when you inevitably start
your podcast she has to be your first
guest do you know who yours were
I don't someone asked this to me on a
podcast the other day that was like what
cartoon character were you most
attracted to growing up and I was like
I've never thought about that before and
then they very easily had a bunch of
answers and so I was like should I have
been thinking about this I don't know
who do we have Pepe LePew like who's a
hot I don't know I because I never
watched Disney I was never like a Disney
kid growing up it was just like nah I
wasn't interested in it and so I think
my like I watch like hey Arnold and
stuff like that growing up but I'm like
that feels I don't think I was sexually
attracted - oh but I'd have to go back
and think about it I don't know but I'm
fascinated that like what your thoughts
were if that was something that you
already kind of like thinking when you
were younger yeah I know I was very
sexual when I was young I had my first
sexual experience was age five it was a
vivid experience with me and a pillow my
friend in her pillow yeah and it was a
time then she went in tattled the next
day and I got in trouble and then after
that day my Barbies were banned from
being naked so there was over yeah but I
remember early on I was actually called
lewd a lot by my family like you're
being very lewd and it's just very into
physical touch and the human body and I
loved loved and I loved and often times
people ask me about that like how did
you find this career yeah I'm like I
think I just rediscovered it I feel like
I naturally knew what was right and good
for me and my purpose wasn't about
discovering it it was going back to
reclaim it
interesting that's really fascinating
and also very cool that you like almost
had this innate sense in yourself of
like wanting to educate and discover
things yeah right this is instructional
I shout out to Jaylin
out there awesome if you don't have
targeted pillow ads after this podcast
I'm gonna be real upset with their
algorithm
okay we're takin let's break and then we
have a bunch of Twitter questions for
you so we'll be right back with not your
deep today we have support from native
think because they have truly been
supporting my pits for they don't even
know how long
Native creates safe simple effective
products that people use every day their
products are filled with trust
ingredients and their natural deodorant
is no different and that's what I'm
talking to you guys about today native
deodorant is formulated without aluminum
parabens and talc and it's with
ingredients found in nature like coconut
oil shea butter tapioca starch I mean I
don't leave my house but I trust that
that's in nature it comes in a wide
variety of enticing scents for men and
women plus they release new
limited-edition that seasonal scents
throughout the year they got coconut and
vanilla lavender and rose you come brand
mint and eucalyptus and mint and you
know I have been rocking this lavender
and rose for a half a second and oh a
girl that hates to bathe no one would
know but now you know cuz I'm telling
you directly and for those that are
sensitive or have sensitivities native
has an unscented formula and a baking
soda free formula so they got something
for everyone making the switch to a
natural deodorant doesn't mean you have
to sacrifice an odor and wetness
protection and they are the proof that's
the reason that they have over eight
thousand five star reviews there's also
a no risk to try it they offer free
shipping and free returns and exchanges
in the USA and now you guys can get 20%
off your first purchase visit native
deodorant calm and use promo code grace
during checkout guys this this is my
go-to every day so please go to native
deodorant comm use promo code grace get
20% off
it's it's
wonderful again native deodorant come
from a coat grace 20% off your first
purchase let me know how great you feel
this is the pits
what I don't know we have support from
better help this week and they're here
to support you if there is something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
they are here to offer help they offer
licensed professional counselors who are
specialized in issues like depression
anxiety relationships trauma anger
family conflicts lgbtq+ matters grief
self-esteem and more you can connect
with a professional counselor in a safe
and private online environment and get
help at your own time at your own pace
everything you share is confidential and
convenient you can schedule secure video
or phone sessions as well as chat and
text with your therapist and if for some
reason you're not happy with your
counselor which happens you can request
a new one at any time for no additional
charge and its affordable and on top of
the affordability you'll get 10% off
your first month with the discount code
grace so why not try it out go to better
help calm slash grace fill out a
questionnaire so that they can assess
your needs and match you with a
counselor that you're loved that's
better help calm slash grace okay we're
gonna get two Twitter questions before
we do I'm gonna ask you the two
questions ask every guest that's on the
podcast and the first is who alive or
dead would you most want to throw cold
spaghetti act oh you know what to be
honest with you it's not really anybody
that truly hate I try to light it it can
be celebratory too celebratory cold
spaghetti just maybe to get their
attention I'm gonna go with grace Helbig
it's my favorite food so you truly you
would understand it I would and I would
know that your intentions are good and
pure yes that's it I'll take it okay the
other question is to tell us your worst
pants shooting story or close call but
you can only use three words or like
small phrases so mine is college jogging
front lawn
Florida pipes are too small
hey I love that you had it locked and
loaded and ready to go like classic most
embarrassing story to ever happen to me
so I'll never forget it unfortunately oh
I love it
that's so good okay let's get into these
Twitter questions
I'm sure you've answered a lot of
similar questions like this before cuz
we got a lot of really like serious
questions and I think it's because
there's such a lack of like education
readily available that people like oh my
god someone that's like making this okay
I have so much to add you're gonna
answer too though
yeah I'll answer - um someone's asking
how do you feel about cancelled culture
nowadays I think that you ever watch
that episode of Black Mirror the one
with the bees no I haven't seen the bees
one of the beat you have to watch the
bees wine it is the most relevant to
social media yeah I haven't seen it I
think that two years ago I substituted I
hate that I don't like that why are you
doing that when that's fascinating tell
me more yeah and so I think that if we
took more time to be tourists for each
other versus tour guides like a tour
guide I know what you write I know we're
supposed to be doing I know where this
goes and a tourist is like well why
don't you put that there yeah why is
that that way for you so I think that
canceled culture is an industry right
yes people get famous off of it they get
big of it so I understand it it's like a
form of entrepreneurialism but I also
think that it stops us from the ultimate
goal which is connecting loving
understanding empathizing with each
other so I try my best not to
participate yeah no I think I agree a
wholehearted with with you on that
because I think that it's a big like
stamp of no two having a dialogue or a
conversation that could help both for
one party grow or see things differently
or understand things differently and
also like Wharton I don't think any of
us are obviously born perfect or with
like the full most updated constant
understanding of like rules regulations
words and different offensiveness miss
out there and so the biggest most
exciting thing to me is when people
choose to educate with kindness
rather than cancel with like regret or
anger in some way and I think you do a
really great job of being open to how to
cancel we had we had something in the
podcast like a year or so ago
where someone guest had said something
that was offensive an idea you're
talking about and if I went do the same
thing with this yeah and it was it was
really difficult to feel a lot of anger
from an audience who didn't give the
entirety of episode even a chance like
because there was nothing related to
that situation anywhere in the episode I
thought it was a really great dialogue
to have with someone and so but you also
never want to dismiss like feelings of
people that have been very supportive of
you and you don't want them to think
that you made a bad decision and that
they can't believe or trust your
instincts unlike who you talk to and how
you talk to people so it's just like a
very strange mix of emotions going on
but I'm sure you've dealt with so much
[ __ ] in that regard oh yeah I get
cancelled pretty like today so I'm I
think maybe like biannually it seems
like I learned from every time I become
a better person and I grow and more
people find out about me and where
people are on the journey and where
people say I don't like what she's doing
then they start to look into what they
do like yeah I just look at it like I am
here to encourage conversation yeah
that's the only way you can otherwise
you just get exhausted yeah I love it
and then you live in a world of anxiety
of not knowing what's safe to say ever
for the rest of your life so I think
dialogue is better okay this is best
advice on serious online dating do's and
don'ts when you want to try to find
something serious okay this person also
says that they need help navigating
their sexual relationship or finding one
that's satisfying for both people they
don't want to be destined to a life of
orgasm less sex that's two questions or
what basically two in one tweet they
really use that extra
like its character count here and that
was me paraphrasing this tweet but best
avenues for serious online dating and
we've got a couple questions about that
that a lot of apps especially in the
LGBTQ community to I have like started
moving more towards like hookup apps
rather than like an opportunity to find
something kind of more grounded serious
meaningful and how to navigate that if
that's not if you don't want to just
hook up but you don't have other ways to
meet people yeah I would say that to me
online dating is a pro tool it's on an
entry point tool so you have to really
have worked on yourself know what you're
looking for being clear about what it is
you want out of a connection and then
also when you're searching for something
serious what you're actually doing is
searching to figure out what you're
serious purr-fectly looks like and so I
think of it less like I'm trying to meet
my person versus I'm trying to get to
know people who bring me closer to my
ideal person so I think with online
dating you have two choices you can do
the work before by getting my book and
reading and research and having a clear
strategy in a plan or you know you can
do it after by just rolling the dice
going on random dates wasting your time
with somebody but you're gonna do the
work regardless like I have a pretty had
a really strict online dating regimen
and through that I met awesome people
and ever met my person but I met the
person who styled my engagement shoot I
met the person who I bought art off of I
met somebody who I gave a graphic design
job to Ahmet awesome people yeah that
actually taught me a lot about what I
truly want in a partnership so stop with
the goal orientation of I'm looking for
something serious versus I'm looking to
get to know really great people who
could add value to my life yeah and if
you do that I think you'll one be more
intentional in your messaging before
more intentional in your search and then
also less disappointed with the results
yeah that's I'm gonna say I love the way
you phrase that because I think if this
person sounds like they're already going
in with the expectations that they're
not gonna find what they want but
instead if they figure out like you said
who brings value rather than who's the
one yes then your expectations can be
broadened and wide open and there's less
disappointment you're less frustrated uh
you got someone that styled your wedding
yeah my engagement shoot your engagement
in this company
called la rocks was a beautiful
beautiful clothes there's like a nice
androgynous it's a really cool shoot so
shadowed you Ricky
very cool good job Rick yes okay let's
see here
Oh someone's to know what's the weirdest
question you get asked in your line of
work I always want to add on to that
like what's the one question you wish
people asked you more hmm so we this
course in school for when I got my
psychology certification that was called
SAR that's like sexual attitude
reassessment and in it we had to watch
like 40 hours of porn basically really
and they showed us every kink not every
but because if you look at the list of
kinks and fetishes it is like Stan
Webster long and so they showed us a
bunch of different Kingston they had
people come in who talked who worked in
the sex space or who were sex workers
that we spoke to like a phone sex
actress who just educated us on what
people are actually into and the goal of
that so that if I'm out there in the
world and you tell me what you like I'm
not gonna be like weird like oh I think
I've seen something similar and when you
watch some things like hard to me for me
to watch was cutting as a yes but when I
watched the video I was like there's
something really quite beautiful about
that being because there is some
euphoria that you get there's a rush
that of adrenaline you get when you do
harm yourself and like to some extent in
a controlled environment that's why I'd
be like oxygen deprivation
we like BDSM and sorry it's not an
abnormal part of life it's just a
sensation that people enjoy if they know
how to control and they found a partner
that can do that way oh my gosh I'm so
happy for you yeah so it was like
watching them I'm like good for them for
finding each other just about that
versus like the shock of it so I don't
think I've gotten any like super crazy
questions the question I wished people
asked more is like what book should I
read yeah yeah I think it's less of like
people will write me these like 40
paragraphs
I don't do DM counseling at all for this
reason yeah I just you can't keep up
with that yeah I know I also think it's
just not really responsible just to
chuck your life story at somebody who
doesn't know you you don't have any
rapport with you don't know what my
system is for fielding questions or it's
also too like disappointing for you
because it's like shouting in a vacuum
yeah
rather than writing me paragraphs of
what happened say hey I'm trying to get
over a breakup what book should I read
that's a lot easy
than me trying to decipher your
situation and write some you know
prolific paragraph to a complete
stranger yeah no I think that's great
and also because like you said there are
so many books yours included out there
that are be my desire books are sold
right everywhere books are sold
the yeah the giving them because I think
they're gonna find more value in that
book than like the small amount of time
you have to craft a very specific answer
for them
well null and void of it being about sex
and relationships what's a question you
wish people asked more of you of me
what's a question that I wish people
asked more of me um well the question
that I've always liked that comes up all
the time that used to be like something
that I just didn't know how to answer
was that what's it like to be a female
in comedy a female and entertainment and
this was like even before like this big
feminist research and all the wonderful
things that are happening for women
right now but I had never just like put
my I wish oh there was a person in
entertainment and like the stories and
point of view that I have about comedy
come from obviously my perspective which
is me growing up as a woman so I never
knew how to answer it I was like I don't
see myself that way I mean it's
difficult to be an entertainment and
it's I think at the time online when I
was like starting [ __ ] find my groove
there weren't a lot of women doing it so
the competition for like anything like
that was even less and the ability to
support the whole like female community
of entertainment it was like so much
easier to do because we were all in it
together figuring it out everything and
so that's the question that always
bothered me but never to a point that it
like made my day bad or anything I just
like felt like I stumbled over how to
answer that and they people asking
seemed like they had some sort of answer
in their brain that they were
anticipating so that was always like I
don't think I'm gonna give you the
answer that you want this but I think I
wish that people asked more and I think
we're starting to have more of a
conversation about this about like the
burnout quality of continuously creating
and generating content I think there's
been a lot of focus on the mental health
side of creating content which I love
that conversation because I do think
it's okay for people to take a break and
you see
that there's been like this blueprint
ish thing figured out for people that
want to get into the digital space or
get into creating content wherever they
can that they have to continuously work
every hour of every day every minute
always be on their phones always be
figuring out how to like connect and
they think it ruins people's
authenticity to have conversations with
people or to like create things it
becomes this like very factory-produced
sort of thing and being able to take
time off and like pivot and figure
things out I think is really important
so that's the thing the conversation
starter I wish people would ask more
have you started to be on safai your
hours you know how they say everyone has
the same 24 hours is beyond saying yeah
how much of a goddamn lie that is
because Beyonce has 200 employees yeah
and so Beyonce can be having a day to
herself in a day off and that could be
her most lucrative day of the year
because her lawyers made some great
deals so for you like are there days
where you don't have to do the grace
that other people are doing the grace
and so that guilt doesn't have to be
there occasionally yeah I think that's a
big thing as delegating and finding
people that you can create a team around
that are better at their job than you
could ever be at their job or better at
doing something that you can do like
very half-assed Lee or very mediocre Lee
and that's always been a struggle for me
it's like creating a team of people or
like outsourcing to people that can do
better I'm always like I can do it on my
own I'll do it I'll do it I mean it
might not be that great but I'll get it
done yes and so yeah being able to rely
and trust others to like help support
your grandiose picture I think is huge
and it can be so small minimal to of
like what you're asking people to do it
doesn't have to be like you have this
giant entourage now of all these people
because Beyonce didn't at one point she
had no one at some point she Disney's
child always but even before 12 in their
living room she's a hard worker and
she's a hustler and of all the above but
I think that people put a lot of guilt
on themselves to be productive 24/7 with
this notion that other people are but I
think that at a certain point it's not
just you and that should be widespread
knowledge yeah I agree I agree put it in
the next book right yeah by this book
yes okay so let's talk about shrimping
yes I know is shrimping really a thing
what is shrimping so you're the good
thing I think all things must be a thing
so I from my interpretation of what I
read based on seeing this tweet so I am
learning all the time I really want to
emphasize that that this is a continual
space where my audience educates me
constantly so what I learned based on
urban dictionary which is a very
reliable source clearly is shrimping is
when you ejaculate on someone's back
okay a body part and then take a straw
and drink it up and drink it up okay but
I've heard different like very you can
use I mean with the 2019 you better you
better use a paper straw right issue is
shrimping how did the two connect I
don't know I also read that it was like
to do with anal sex and it was the straw
is the consistent that I did read okay
the straw but where the semen goes for
you to then shrimp it up okay that is
inconsistent but I would love to hear
from your viewers maybe who have a
better more concrete explanation yeah is
it a thing I think all things are a
thing I think in this print in history
people have done every possible
configuration of the thing yeah maybe it
goes by a different term but yeah let us
know tweeted us if this is a thing if
you've if you have first-hand experience
with it I guess and how it got this name
yes that's that's always the most
curious one sitting etymology not that
the term for it of it Oh something like
that okay something like that we don't
discuss those things on this show
someone wants to know oh how to talk
about using sex toys in the bedroom when
it's too soon or too late there's no
such thing as too soon or too late and I
think that we are often waiting to have
like way to even the dialogue of where
is this going right people is too soon
to have that it's like you wouldn't show
up to a job being like I don't know what
my role is I don't want to be 204 I'm
asking like you better know if you're
interning or you're supervising etc yeah
you better know because the key to
happiness is the key to happiness is
managing expectations yeah and so you
have to be clear about what it is that
the exchange is happening when you go to
Subway sandwiches you're clear on the
exchange dollars and you're getting this
tuna sandwich right
being 14 getting tuna even the tunas
Bhama maybe like disappointed yeah so I
think that if you get off using toys
that's a very big part of your sexual
pleasure your arousal cycle it's never
too soon to bring it up because this is
what sexually engaging with you
successfully looks like yeah so I would
say in that case it's just casual I
think too we put all this like gravitas
pressure ease that conversation yeah
like again
sex ed should be sexy talking about sex
should be sexy yeah shouldn't be like
okay so there's something I have to tell
you yes please turn off your phone don't
speak to your mom for 24 hours like it's
like what do you want to stay you know
literally just be honest or get the
vibrator necklace which is this really
approachable cute way and it can be used
on the taint it can be used on the vulva
can be used on the clitoris do not
insert it's not made for that cuz it
heats up but nonetheless like you can
bring in sort of entry-level toys gauge
their reaction and then have discussions
about it yeah I think like you're saying
you approach it how you would want to be
approached with this conversation like
you don't want someone saying like you
need to sit down we need to have a talk
it's gonna feel uncomfortable oh my god
what's going on like really I think make
it fun cuz this is ultimately supposed
to be fun for both of you have you ever
had a partner tell you that they're into
something or want to do something that
was like oh that's interested we have to
have a discussion about it beforehand um
I don't think it's ever been anything
that we've had like a full discussion
about I think there's been things that
I'm like oh you're into that okay we can
try that and see but it's not like let
me figure out the psychology of wire
into this before we start talking about
it it's more of like okay that's
manageable to me if it was something
that obviously was like completely out
of left field and that would be
something worth having a conversation
but it's always been like I feel like
I've been with partners that I respect
very much and have a lot of respect for
me so it's never been like a very
imbalanced form of like control or want
or need or expectation sort of thing
knock on wood thankfully I definitely
like okay you brought this up this is
point of something okay great let's do
it thank you for just not just doing
this yes see what my reaction would be
thank you for even mentioning this and
so that's yeah never the full
conversation though I think take
advantage of the fact that the world
wide web is provided in encyclopedia of
different ways people sexually engage I
love porn so yeah I've got a visual
reference to show somebody to say I saw
this video made me think of you what do
you think or my favorite thing is like I
had a dream you know I had a dream in
tonight and we were role-playing and it
was really hot and then just gauging the
person's response and say do you think
we could do that so yeah he's finding
fun approachable ways to begin the
dialogue in a way that resembles what
good sex is yeah and sensual fine hot
cool sometimes a little embarrassing
sometimes there's queefs but you keep
going and you get hit sex can be funny
and that's okay too
the other day my partner we had like you
know doggy style sex and then he had was
giving me oral afterwards and it's like
the queefs you can't if you're doing
doggy style and it was like I was like a
cat like it was hitting him in the
forehead it's appropriate to bring up
and ask afterwards like did you so their
ability to not bring it up on there and
maybe that's the Pilatus thing with your
nose okay what are you up to next what's
coming down the pipeline for you I mean
book obviously still available everyone
can go and should go get it is it
available in audiobook yes
yeah I read that mother mother yeah so I
mean next is just continuing the work
that I do finding ways to collaborate
with people to bring the conversation of
sex education to the forefront this is a
really big deal for me grace you know
what you do and how approachable you are
and how big your star is and so to bring
this conversation to this podcast like I
would probably say somebody asked me
like last week I'm like what snacking
i'ma be on Christmas well you have to
now start your own podcast and have you
ever thought about like I know you've
done some book touring stuff like a tour
kind of thing like yeah girl I mean same
as you was like have I literally thought
about it because do I want to sit down
and play it's always a joke Treece month
like come to Chicago and you're like you
got some work for me to stay like where
am i speaking like what's the deal Delta
points the house is working yeah shame
before you go every guest that's on the
podcast gets a personalized fortune
cookie for being here oh my goodness
yeah did you write the message inside we
yeah you know it's different
oh wow this one is not Orthodox Lee
folded no they never are okay so it's
it's this this feels like shrimping yeah
Mary says oh my gosh this is audio nice
hard to get out okay I did it
alright wow this is a scroll yeah
alright you were right it wasn't chanel
it was bacterial vaginosis that was
embarrassing
you were right comment from somebody no
that's a reflection on what you
commented it was a confession from them
and I'm like that situation and was like
that's gross in that classic like trolls
to to stank and yes she's like that's
disgusting I'd rather wear Chanel with
what is the most helpful thing about
time telling them what might actually be
problematic with their mom but
and that they should go seek medical
it's wonderful okay sham where can
people find you online if they don't
know where can they get the book etc the
book is available everywhere books for
souls called the game of desire I'm
gonna stop there because you get one
wish with people that's my wish but
follow her read the book she's got
nothing but amazing information and
thank you so much for Kari this of
course you think I was just like very
older no it's it's edible that's as far
as alright we'll see you guys next time
I'm not too deep good bye 2deep 2deep
2deep 2deep whatever struggles you are
currently facing depression anxiety
trauma grief better help can connect you
with a professional counselor in a safe
and private online environment it is so
convenient that you can schedule secure
video and phone sessions as well as chat
and text with your therapist and
anything you share is completely
confidential and best of all it's
affordable and you will get 10% off your
first month with the discount code grace
so why not get started go to better help
calm slash grace fill out a
questionnaire and get matched with a
counselor that you'll love today not too
deep is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer Melissa Dumont's
writing by Diane Kang a production
assistants by Katrina Henning
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]